في الاثناء قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان الوزير انتينا بلينكن اتصل بقائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وناقش
المحادثات الجاريه في مدينه جده
وافاد بيان للخارجيه الامريكيه
لاعمال العنف التي ارتكبتها القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع واضاف البيان
ان بلينكن اكد للبرهان ان التوصل لاتفاق
في جده سيسمح بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
والخدمات الاساسيه التي يحتاجها الشعب
السوداني بشده
للمزيد انضم الينا من جده مراسل الجزيره
بدر الربيعان ومن شمال ام درمان مراسل
الجزيره عبد الباقي الظافر اهلا بكما
وابدا معك بدر وتفاصيل اكثر حول ظروف
توقيع هذا يعني الاتفاق وايضا البيان
الصادر
نعم عبد السلام نتحدث عن اعلان اتفاق
الهدنه بعد انتهاء جوله المفاوضات الثانيه
بين الطرف النزاع السودانيه الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع ووقف اطلاق نار قصير الامد
سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد 48 ساعه اي يوم
الاثنين مساء ويمكن تمديده بموافقه
الطرفين اتفاق الهدنه ينص على فتح ممرات
انسانيه لايصال المساعدات اضافه الى
مراقبه تحركات الطرفين نزاع عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه وهذا حقيقه ما تمت الحديث عنه في
اليه متابعه الاتفاق بين الطرفين على
الارض من قبل رجال المتابعه الخاصه بهذا
الاتفاقيه في اعلان جدا الاول ايضا اشار
الان الطرفين اتفق على ايصال وتوزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه استعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه وكذلك ايضا سحب القوات
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه اشار
كذلك الى الاتفاق على تسهيل الامور
والمرور الامن لمقدمي المساعدات الانسانيه
ما يسمح بالتدفق المساعدات من الموانع الى
السكان محتاجين وبرود اخرى بالتاكيد تتعلق
بضبط النزاع بضوابط انسانيه بهدف تخفيف
اثار الصراع على المدنيين يمكن حقيقه
البناء على برود اعلان جدا الاول الخاص
بالمباحثات والالتزامات التي وقع عليها
الطرفان هذا البيان اشار الى ان البحثات
اللاحقه ستركز على خطوات اخرى لتحسين
الظروف الامنيه وكذلك الانسانيه المدنيين
وهذا ما تركز عليه المباحثات حقيقه
الجاريه هنا في جده بما في ذلك تشريعي
ازاله العوائق التي تحد من حريه حركه
المدنيين والجهات الفاعله الانسانيه ايضا
المباحثات التي جرت في جده تبحث في
ترتيبات تنفيذ اعلان جده على ارض الواقع
بما فيها مده التنفيذ وفتح الممرات
الانسانيه كذلك اضافه الى عدد من البنود
التي تم التوقيع عليها والتفاهم حولها اذا
نتحدث عن المرحله الثانيه من اعلان جده
التي سيعقوبها وفقا لمصدر في وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه مناقشات ومفاوضات موسعه
لوقف اطلاق نار دائم هذه هي الجوله
الثانيه للمباحثات وللتجري برعايه سعوديه
امريكيه وبحضون المبعوث الامه السوداني
اضافات الى ممثل الرباعيه الدوليه هذا
الاتفاق عبد السلام ياتي بعد القمه
العربيه التي عقدت امس هنا في جده والتي
تحدث فيها ولي العهد السعودي عن امله في
ان تكون لغه الحوار هي الاساس للحفاظ على
وحده السودان وامن شعبها ومقدراته اشار
الى ان المباحثات تركز على وقف فعال
لاطلاق النار ورحل بتوقيع طرفي النزاع على
اعلان جده ايضا هذه المباحثات تهدف الى
دراسه الاليات الممكنه لهاء النزاع
بالسودان ولا يوجد سقف زمني محدد لنهايتها
والحقيقه للقائمون عليها هنا يسعون الى ان
تصل الى مفاوضات جاده وحقيقيه تصل
بالطرفين الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار راتب
للسلام